beautiful day for baseball 79 degrees
and a beautiful day for trey turner to
make his first start in a dodgy
uniformity
leading off and starting at second base
taking a look at what julio reyes has
done lately
overall this season 13 wins to lead the
majors and the number one strikeout to
walk ratio in the national league
over that stretch you can see that he
has been very hot
up the middle heading to center field
upton turns second and holds there
and the angels have first and second
with nobody out
as david fletcher finds a hit suzuki
three for 42
against breaking balls this year 1-2
pitch
throws it again and strikes him out oh
bumpy
takeoff in this first inning but it's
smooth landing for julio
and maria goes trying to follow up on
two really nice starts
yeah they're giving up a couple of home
runs if he starts to go he's been
dominating my go-to is to keep that
dominance going for
me berea today so this is exciting times
for dodger fans to be able to watch this
guy play on a daily basis
he's worked at fallen on a 3-2 pitch
takes ball four
lead off lock trey turner the man aboard
for max muncie
about another six inches already further
creeping
muncie lines it by the left center field
base it into the gap
and a chance to watch trey turn around
he'll score from first on a muncie
[Applause]
making those left turns and blazing home
to make it one nothing
seeger smacks one through the left side
base hill
to the vacated left side of the infield
with the shift on
two-nothing dodgers
[Applause]
and berea with the breaking ball strikes
out smith but the dodgers
just like last night have jumped to a
two-nothing lead
that's joe madden again hitting the
pitcher eight so now the nine hitter
jack mayfield who has hit anything
but like a nine hitter
roller to third for turner and quickly
after the lead off walk
maria sits him down in order two nothing
middle two
taylor swings and misses and berea
strikes out the left fielder of the
dodgers 10 15 years ago not many
managers would do that
because they wanted guys that had the
range
marias goes down berea looks better in
the second it's two nothing
[Music]
dodgers breaking ball looks like he was
fooled and he swings through it
third cave for aureus one gone in the
third
so you just your mindset is he's gonna
make contact you just gotta defend it
fletcher left field taylor after it
looking up
and it's off the wall
and he pulls in with a double and that's
a great example of what we were just
talking about
oftentimes especially layton counts
he'll shoot a ball down the right field
line and here he yanks one in the left
center gap for a double iglesias last
time up
didn't get the job done this is where he
comes back hammers that one
and it's fair and it's into the corner
that gets the job done
fletcher will score and it's 2-1
he is so clutch there's ignacius the big
double
yesterday in the 10th big double here in
the third
now goslin maria's got him to hit a fly
ball out to left
up the middle into center field round
third
headed home here comes iglesias
he's in there that's a close play
fighters may look at that is why cody
bellinger
is special i mean that is a great throw
charged it well
but iglesias with a good slide avoids
the tag
now field playing adele deep and
straight up
cut that off the end of the bat pops it
up out in front of the plate who's going
to get there
muncie and he dropped it in a run scores
and the angels have the lead
muncie had trouble last night at second
going into shallow right in the tent
had to go a long way for this one
jaime berea that's a nice comeback to
get seeger
three innings in 3-2 injury
three runs on four hits dodgers have two
runs three hits and an error
and mayfield trying to butt and it's a
beauty
checks up nicely that's a base hit
that's one of those ones there's a
picture he like wait but this guy has
all these home runs
since the all-star break and you bunt
like that that good
the captain
off the end of the bat turner lunges to
get it feeds the other turner who
gets it to first a double play justin
detrey
onto first double play to the bottom of
the fourth
3-2
[Applause]
taylor flies one to right joe adele
coming on still coming plays it on a
bounce
and goes into the seats
taylor to second smith the third
this is a ground rule
[Applause]
now you can't throw from there so it's
already ruled a ground rule double
you can't throw from inside the dugout
and you can't throw from the stands and
the the veterans got a kick out of that
it's nice to have dexter fowler back
he's a terrific clubhouse guy
hit hard captures it that saves a couple
nicely done and maria escapes the fourth
bounce back to the mound past durias
trey turner got ready to go quickly and
got him
to keep it a 3-2 game halfway home in
l.a
turner shoots the basic the other way
his first hit is the dodger lead off
single here in the fifth
there he goes swinging a miss throw down
no
chance so trey turner tonight his first
start
his first walk his first run his first
hit
his first steal in a dodger uniform spin
on a slider has been effective this
getting them out in front enough where
they're not getting the barrel on it
on the ground iglesias gobbles it up
jaime berea 85 pitches in has a 3-2 lead
at dodger stadium you have to really
work hard to get the ball down
sooner and if you're a four-seat pitcher
at the top you got to do the same
trey turner diving stop jump throw it
again
he's showing l.a what he's got tonight
we've seen him charge a ball now we see
him go to his right we've seen the speed
on the bases with the stolen base we've
seen him score from first and now we see
this stays on faces cody bellinger
[Applause]
ties it up at three and a brand new ball
game
game perhaps on the line here two gone
in the eighth inning and shohei ohtani
another one too
see what the dodgers can do in this 3-3
tie 2-0 here it comes taylor
takes one to left center field turns the
game it's down
he gets by the wall zigger's in
here comes smith
12 pitches last night for the big fella
to get his inning in the books
he's at eight now he's got a chance to
beat what he did last night
on the first pitch from janssen fletcher
pops one
shadow center trey turner ends the night
exclamation from trey turner
on a 5-3 dodger win
you